je vous le disais en titre la sécurité
civile organise son opération cadets en
eure-et-loir elle est organisée par le
sdi c'est le lycée professionnel gilbert
courtois de dreux les jeunes volontaires
recevront leur diplôme à la fin de la
semaine
nathalie héros avec didier le pape voici
huit pompiers junior cette semaine ils
apprennent les gestes de secours
manipuler un extincteur ou éteindre un
feu
je fais la formation pour connaître la
valeur des pompiers donc l'esprit de
famille l'esprit d'équipé sens je
pourrai intervenir dans les cuisines en
cas de danse en gym ou même au niveau se
courir vont s'ouvrir la personne en cas
de malaise de
enfin si elle respire puma en tant que
massage cardiaque
tous sont volontaires
une fois leur diplôme en poche ils
auront le rôle de référent sécurité au
lycée lors des exercices d'évacuation et
sont présents ils peuvent faire
également détourné ce sont des vigies de
haut niveau de l'établissement
quand ils passent dans l'établissement
qui voit un extincteur par exemple qui
est des plombes et ils doivent le
signaler à la direction de manière à ce
qu'on puisse remédier à ce problème là
le colonel vincent allard est à
l'origine du projet selon lui ce genre
d'initiative atténue les violences
urbaines
ce type d'opération participe aussi au
fait de faire passer des messages aux
jeunes qui vivent ici dans un quartier
qui est concret qui est prioritaire mais
et on a vu l'évolution que ça pouvait
avoir donc la formation de ces jeunes
c'est bien sûr au lycée mais c'est aussi
dans leur quartier participer à la agir
à la paix sociale et à faire évoluer les
mentalités dans leur quartier les lui
lycéens recevront leur diplôme de cadets
de la sécurité civile à la fin de la
semaine
depuis 2011 les pompiers